Nu menar jag den här frågan.
Jag försöker ställa den på ett kärleksfullt sätt, men den kommer att låta jättedryg.
Varför skulle det här vara en bättre utbildning än en annan?
Vad är det ni gör duktigt liksom?
Nej men det är hybris.
Vi har ju det.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan ett bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Jens Bäckbom till podden.
Jens är en av grunderna till Pareto Business School.
Idag ser jag fram emot att höra lite om vad jag gör fel och vad jag har misslyckats med under min tid som människa.
Jens tillhör också en av de här människorna som när man går in och ska kolla på en CV så måste man klicka i den här snabbknappen på hjulet på musen för att man ska kunna skrolla igenom allting.
Det är en jävla massa styrelser och ledamotsuppdrag och investeringsgrejer.
Varför är det så Jens?
Kul att vara här till att börja med men.
Har du levt ett aktivt liv?
Det finns ju det här begreppet insecure overachiever.
Man börjar en utbildning en gång i tiden och en av de första man träffar säger att jag läser en till utbildning också som jag redan har börjat läsa och man själv tänkte så här.
Okej, det räcker inte med att börja läsa en utbildning.
Okej, och sen får man dåligt självförtroende och sen så ska man själv också göra det med minst hand för att man ska tänka att man ska se vad man klarar av.
Alltså när jag var ung så var det definitivt, fortfarande ganska ung men när jag var yngre så var det definitivt sådär att om man tänker på kompisar som var långa, starka och liksom sprang fort skulle testa sig genom att bli kustjägare eller liksom fallkampsjägare eller jag hade en klasskompis som var båtchef i lumpen det verkade väldigt köttigt liksom.
Jag hade ganska lätt för mig i skolan så då vill man också testa så här men okej men vad klarar jag faktiskt av då?
Det fanns definitivt en sådan en sådan aspekt.
Så här efterhand, om jag kunde gå tillbaks till min till liksom 19-20-våriga Jens och klappa honom på huvudet och genom en kram så skulle jag säga så här men du tar lugnt och liksom gör något som är kul framförallt.
Gör inte grejer bara för att det är svårt.
Så höll jag definitivt på i den åldern och det ska man inte göra.
Det är bättre att göra grejer som är roliga.
Man kan fortfarande vara ambitiös och liksom tjatta på men över tid så blir det bättre om man gör grejer som man har lite fallnhet för eller som går lite mer av sig själv.
Det är nog ett långt svar på hur det började.
Sen på slutet jag menar man...
Kan jag inte bara få säga och då...
För är det inte lite bullshit?
Du har ju ändå, nu har du ju startat Pareto Business School här för ett par år sedan.
Är det inte lite ett halvkrångligt projekt att dra igång en businessutbildning som ska konkurrera?
Det känns ju inte som det där man bara hoppar in i direkt utan du kommer ju bli granskad, du kommer ju få vad ska man säga, ganska kritiska kunder.
Du kommer behöva sälja in det, du behöver ta fram allting.
Det är ingenting man gör på en handvändning.
Känner du att det här är bara kul?
Var det inte lite utmaningen i att det var svårt?
Så här, den här utbildningen är lite av ett kärleksbarn mellan mig och min medgrundare Mattias.
Vi kände båda två att det vi läste på handels var ganska akademiskt flumigt.
Särskilt när man själv skulle driva bolag sen och inser att vad den fina teorin ska jag ha den till när jag ska säga upp någon.
Eller när jag ska in och göra en förhandling med någon.
Och det hade vi fördelen, båda två.
Vi gick en termin vardera på klassiska MBAI program.
Jag i USA och Mattias i England.
Där är det mycket mer praktiskt.
Där, kom ihåg, i en kurs så läste vi ett aktieöverlåtelsavtal.
Så här ser det ut.
Så här är det stycke för stycke, det här är det det står, det här betyder ungefär.
Och jag kommer ihåg att det slog med att det här skulle aldrig hända på handels.
Det här är det som händer i verkligheten ungefär.
På handels, då är teorin om företagsöverlåtelser och den så kallade effektiva marknadshypotesen och annat.
Trams.
Alltså så här, jag ska inte hata på handelsionödan.
Handels är jättebra såklart.
Det här är, jag brukar säga att det är en safe space den här podden.
Här får man vara vem man vill.
Nej men, man kan se det som att, om man är 18-19, 20 och ska börja läsa på högskola och vill ha en akademisk grund, så finns det jättemånga bra utbildningar man kan gå.
Och det handlar mer om att man ska lära sig, gå upp på morgonen, bädda sängen och liksom läsa, det är ett långt IQ-test delvis, men det är också bara när man lär sig problemlösningar och allt sånt där.
Men när man är vuxen och ska inte ha tid och ska lära sig någonting, då brukar jag tänka på när jag gick på mellanstadiet och min lärare sa att du ska lära dig skrivstil.
Och jag var såhär, vad ska jag lära mig skrivstil för?
Det tar ju bara tid.
Och det går långsammare att läsa.
Nej men du behöver det på högstadiet.
Kommer du till högstadiet var det ingen som sa att jag skulle skriva skrivstil.
Och då kände jag mig lurad och då kände jag mig såhär, men ska jag starta utbildning så ska jag ha sådant man kan använda.
Eller missa, men försöka.
Sen kommer inte alla kunna använda allt.
Då är det en sådan utbildning svårare att designa.
Men definitivt försöka ta så mycket saker som möjligt från verkliga händelser, verkliga entreprenörer, verkliga arbetsdokument, verkligheten.
Men är denna, bara för att knyta an till det vi var på i början där, är utbildningen gjord för att nu har du gjort lite karriärsgrejer, är detta din payback, nu får du bara göra det som är kul?
Eller är det mer, detta ska bli en intressant utmaning, undrar om det här går?
Alltså, så här kan man väl säga, det är ju inte för att vi tror att det här är en affärsidé man kan tjäna absolut mest pengar på.
Det tror vi inte.
Det finns definitivt, jag har jobbat mest med SAS-bolag på olika sätt.
Jag startade SAS-bolag, har investerat i ett gäng SAS-bolag via mitt jobb på Almirvest.
Det finns fortfarande, jag är övertygad om, ganska mycket pengar att hämta i SAS, om man, särskilt med AI och, man kan bygga saker ganska fort nu, eller väldigt fort.
Men det finns definitivt ställen man kan tjäna mer pengar, det tror jag.
Det här gör vi också för att det är, det känns genuint roligt.
Jag har alltid tyckt att utbildning är någonting fint.
Jag har alltid tyckt att det är, jag har av och till, jag har även nu plockat upp det igen, varit volontär och lärde ut matte på gymnasieskolor.
Tycker det är otroligt meningsfullt.
Det är mycket därför vi har startat det här.
Vi tycker så här, det borde finnas någon slags utbildning av det här slaget.
Vi försöker göra det bästa vi kan, och försöker intervjera det.
Sen kommer det säkert, som du säger, det kommer vara sådana som tycker att det här var inte för mig.
Det här passade, jag kunde det här, eller det här var, vad håller ni på med?
Men vi gör det definitivt mycket för att vi vill verkligen sprida kunskap.
Vi tycker det är roligt, genuintroligt.
Utbildningen baserad på, nu hoppade vi nästan över hela din, vem du är här, vi hoppade ju bara rakt in i, så vi får nästan komma till det sen.
Men jag vill bara fråga, är utbildningen baserad på din och din medgrundare affärsliv?
Eller har ni, och liksom lärdomarna som ni tyckte att man behövde, eller har ni gjort någon sorts forskning på det här är, vad normalt sett en utbildning innehåller?
Och nu försöker vi trycka in det i utbildningen på ett effektivt sätt.
Med det senare tror jag, eller vi har faktiskt fått höra det från några deltagare, men varför pratar ni inte över huvud taget om er egna bolag?
För det gör vi faktiskt inte, vi har inte, annat än i förbifarten så har vi nämnt det någon gång.
Och det är klart att man är lite färgad av, det kanske finns lite för mycket SaaS-bolag i utbildningen om man jämför med en traditionell MBA, det gör det ju.
Men det är absolut inte, det är långt ifrån bara det.
Så det vi har försökt göra är väl att titta på hur kan man göra så, hur kan man utbilda effektivt och då är det ju en del av det.
Om man tar de här engelska orden effectiveness och efficiency, efficiency är att använda rätt metoder.
Och då tycker vi att vi läste ryska i försvaret, både jag och Mattias en gång i tiden, och vi tyckte att gamlahetliga glotlappar, det var himla effektivt för att lära sig.
Framförallt ord, vokabulär och sådär, det är väldigt mycket sånt i business.
Framförallt trebokstavsförkortningar, det är väldigt många trebokstavsförkortningar.
Så vi har gjort ett gratis gloslappskit också som vi har därute, som man bara kan titta på med 100 trebokstavsförkortningar.
Särskilt marknadsförare verkar älska att hålla på med sådana.
Ja, det känns som...
Ska man lyssna på någon av de här poddarna inom just sälj-
och marknadsföring, då får man nästan fråga dig efter den här PDFen.
Ja, verkligen.
Vi brukar ju ibland...
Vi har ju en hel del gästföreläsare som kommer in under den här utbildningen.
Vi brukar ibland stoppa dem, eller vi stoppar dem sedan den här tiden.
Nu sa du CPA, vad betyder CPA?
Nu blev det PPC, vad är det nu då?
Det är mycket så.
Så det ena är efficiency, att välja metoder.
Då tycker vi att en viktig del av metoden är bara att det utspritt över flera veckor.
Att det inte är...
Vi skulle ju ha tryckt in det på en vecka i streck, men då kommer du att glömma alltihop.
Så lite av poängen är att det är utspritt.
Och lite av poängen är att vi mixar med metod.
Att du får en del för studievideos, övningar, Excel-snurror, Globeslappar och sånt.
Och en del att läsa och så där.
Men sen träffas vi ett par gånger i veckan.
Man lär sig så mycket mer när du är i en grupp med andra, så att du är tvungen att vara lite påläst.
Du kan inte bara slappa dig igenom.
För varje vecka ska du lösa caset, då skickar vi ut i ett breakout room och då bör du nog ha läst på.
Så det gör väldigt mycket.
Sen är en andra del en effectiveness, att vad är det man lär sig.
Och där blir det subjektivt, vad tycker vi är det som har varit mest användbart av det vi har lärt oss på olika ställen och genom eget yrkesliv och genom sånt vi tycker oss har sett att andra har gjort rätt.
Jag hade ganska dåligt självförtroende när vi startade det här, på så vis att vi har gjort väldigt många intervjuer med andra.
Det är säkert 30 intervjuer vi har gjort, spelt in videomaterial, klippte, klippte, klippte, försökt ta ut så här bara.
Vi har en intervju med Christopher Reus, som är väl den entreprenör som satt flest bolag på börsen i Sverige.
För vi vågar inte säga vad man ska tänka på för att sätta bolag på börsen, så därför frågar vi honom vad man ska tänka på.
Så vi har ju försökt bygga någonting som är där vi är mer någon slags vägledare genom ett material som vi har satt ihop med hjälp av andra.
Sen är det klart att vissa grejer kan vi också dra för att vem som helst skulle kunna sitta och läsa om vad är fasta rörliga kostnader.
Det kan vi göra, det kan någon annan göra.
Men det är kul när man får de här lite bakom kulisserna med en sådan som Krister som kan dra lite paralleller mellan sju bolag.
Så det är väl det långa svaret på hur vi försöker göra det.
Men det är ju långt ifrån samma program nu som det var när vi startade.
Vi har ju säkert slängt 60% av första versionen och är 70% kanske.
Jag bara känner att det finns ju mycket, det är ju tydligt att det finns lite passion här också i det här ämnet.
Det är väldigt kul, så är det.
För de som lyssnar så kommer jag bara sammanfatta ner några andra punkter såhär.
Vi skiter helt i Jens som privatperson idag, hans tidigare erfarenhet här.
Ni får googla honom.
Pareto Business School är egentligen, bara för att konkretisera, det var i alla fall en åtta veckors deltidsutbildning där man egentligen får en kondenserad version av en MBA då.
Och man gör det x antal timmar, typ fem timmar per vecka, uppdelat på lite olika områden.
Både hemsstudier och videoföreläsningar och liknande.
Jag bara spiddar upp det lite grann så vi kan gå in i det gosiga liksom.
Min första fråga är, kan man verkligen kalla en åtta veckors utbildning för en MBA?
Absolut inte, det är därför vi använder term mini MBA så ofta.
Det är som att säga Karlsberg, probably the best beer, fair enough.
Nej men absolut, och det är riktigt, det kan man inte.
Det finns faktiskt, man kan till och med kolla på Wikipedia, det finns en sida som handlar om mini MBAs.
Så det är ändå ett koncept som vi har försökt anamma.
Det finns varianter som kallas för pre MBAs också, som är mer det du läser in på sommaren innan du ska gå en vanlig MBA.
Så att nej, vi försöker att ändå, på så många ställen vi kan skriva ut att det här inte är en traditionell MBA, utan det är en mini version, mini MBA.
Och vi hoppas att vi gör det så tydligt vi kan för alla, att du kommer inte få akademiska poäng för det här.
Och däremot så är det, det är såklart kraftigt inspirerat av vad vi själva har läst på en MBA.
Och det ska väl signalera att det inte är en ledarskapskurs, för exempel.
Det är inte heller en kurs i finansiell analys, utan det är en kurs i många olika aspekter av att driva bolag.
Vem, vid vilken nivå är det man ska gå den här utbildningen?
Är det liksom innan man, man kommer ut som student, man är färdig och så är det, är detta liksom en mer praktisk version av det eller liksom en verklig version eller är det när man har drivit bolag ett par år eller är det om man, jag ju gick upp och blev chef.
Vem passar den här kursen för liksom?
Det här du sätter fingret på är den svåraste frågan vi har.
Vi vet inte.
Vilka verkar nöjda liksom?
Vem verkar missnöjd?
De som är nöjda är ju de som är, det handlar mer om inställning tror jag, än någonting annat.
Det är ju de som är kunskapstörstiga.
Det är de som är nöjdast.
Vi serverar inte det så jättelätt åt alla, utan det är liksom ett bootcamp lite grann, och det är ett intellektuellt gym i åtta veckor.
Så om man är inte sugen på det, då ger det inte så mycket.
Vi har ju mycket hemuppgifter, att nu har du tre veckor på dig att förhandla någonting.
Ta en leverantör du har, du kanske är i någon form av diskussion med en, och sen ska vi prata om den här onsdagen om tre veckor.
Om man om hälften inte har gjort det då, då ger det ju inte så mycket när de andra diskuterar det.
Så det är definitivt en faktor.
Det är inte bara något man glider igenom, utan vi gör det för att man ska lära sig något.
Och ofta lära sig är ju ofta lite smärtsamt.
Men ni har ingen sön, du måste sparka någon nästa vecka.
Nej då, men vi har faktiskt experimenterat med det senaste gången att vi...
Nej, nej, nej.
Nej men vi har jobbat med ett bolag som har professionella skåditar som du får en timme med.
Och om du är frivillig då och vill göra det så att säga, då får du öva på ett svårt samtal.
Vi har ett scenario där som är en performance review och du har ett scenario som är att se upp någon.
Och den här skådelsen då är proffs på det.
Så att den börjar gråta och du får hantera en ganska jobbig situation.
Sen får du feedback.
Nej men du, nu var du ju alldeles så mycket du vet, så du ska vara mycket mer rakt på sak, du kan inte hålla på och verka tveksam.
Säger en uppsägning, säger en uppsägning, du måste vara tydlig med det.
Försök igen, så får man faktiskt, vi är ju vera deltagare som var helt omskakade av det där, det var helt makalöst.
Vi har ju deltagare som gick ut efteråt och faktiskt skulle säga upp mig själv, på riktigt.
Då hade de fått en riktig Torr-Sims-version av det.
Kan vi få den feedbacken, det bästa feedbacken om man ska skryta lite, det är ju att folk får göra...
Ibland så är det så att man bara får en uppgift av någon.
Att nu ska du den här veckan vara en tuffing i förhandlingar.
Okej, då liksom det som har folk sagt, gå in i skådespelarhatten och så bara nu ska jag tydligen vara tuff den här veckan.
Och sen så kommer de tillbaka och säger, nej men ni sa ju att jag skulle förhandla den här veckan så nu har jag konsumtat mina leverantörer här och nu har jag fem istället för tio och jag har tjänat en halv miljon om året på det här, tack ska ni ha.
Och det slutade med att det är faktiskt några som har gjort det där nu så att det börjar komma upp i några miljoner som man har förhandlat tillbaks på den här kursen.
Och då är det ju kul.
Det är ju det vi vill åt, att man faktiskt spelar med lite och tar till sig.
Så det är vackert att fråga vem som får ut någonting av det här.
Bakgrundsmässigt så har vi haft allt ifrån personer utan högskoleutbildning som har jobbat i industrin.
Vi har haft personer som har PHD i kemi och blir laboratoriechef, men aldrig haft en kunddialog hela sitt liv tidigare.
Men är du inte lite på väg mot att säga nu att det finns väldigt många som har nytta av detta, men inte en av de stora att man måste nisha sig, är det inte något man lär ut på den här kursen?
Jo, det vi säger är väl så här, det passar bäst om du är i ett tillväxtbolag på något sätt.
Det är definitivt en sån.
Ska du förvalta en butik som redan står där, då finns det andra som kan peka på en utbildning som du förmodligen ska gå istället.
Men är du lite i tillväxt så har vi ganska mycket att komma med.
Det är väl en lilla nischning vi har.
Men det där är kämpigast, en MBA är ju inte en nischprodukt, en traditionell MBA.
Det är en generalistprodukt.
Kanske är det lite mer för personer som är generalister som kanske kommer att flytta sig till en annan bransch.
Kanske kommer att vara säljchef i lite olika bolag, HR-chef i lite olika bolag, entreprenörer som kommer att testa lite olika affärsidéer.
Kanske.
Men jag håller med.
Det där är vårt största bekymmer.
Det kommer journalister att gå.
Vi har haft flera journalister som har gått.
Affärsjournalister.
Är man intresserad av olika aspekter, av att driva bolag så, vi har många entreprenörer som har gått, som har ju många miljoner vinst.
Vi är ju samman med, jag vet inte vad vi ska lära dig men du kan ju uppenbarligen driva bolag.
Men de kommer ut och säger så här, förhandlingsövningen, till exempel, nej men det här var jättevärdefullt, jag lärde mig att betala igen sig på den.
Nej men jag fattar, nej vad kul.
Jag tänkte när, för det är ju en relativt kort utbildning eller vad man ska säga, det är ju en lång utbildning om man ska jämföra med vissa andra kurser, men liksom, du har ju åtta veckor och det är ju som du säger, det är ju antagligen en person som redan har ett jobb eller som är i ett jobb, så man har ju ett exa antal timmar.
Hur gör ni för att, jag vet ju att du brinner för det här med effektivitet och efficiency, men liksom, någonstans är det ju så att när man sitter och lär sig, om någon bara säger till mig, i en förhandling ska du tänka på de här tre punkterna.
Absolut, det är väl jättebra.
Men jag måste ju liksom ha en story eller jag måste ha ett case eller jag måste få ett sätt att reflektera kring det, för annars kommer jag liksom inte införliva det i mitt liv.
Utan då blir det bara en sån där LinkedIn-text som någon lägger upp med typ, här är ett citat, det är viktigt att alla ska må bra på arbetsplatsen.
Absolut, ge mig ingenting i verkligheten.
Hur gör man liksom balansen där när man har en så begränsad tid men ändå ser till att folk ska använda det?
Hur ska man tänka effektivt?
Nej men, det är en jättebra fråga.
Det är, vi försöker ju få in en del storytelling.
Ibland kan enkla budskap gå fram bättre om de packas in i en story.
Det är mycket att vi intervjuar personer som kan berätta om sina bolagsbyggen och bakas det in lite i en anekdot så kan det ta bättre.
Sen är det ju en fråga om, jag vill ju tro att mycket av företagandet är beteenden, att vara påt hela tiden, att liksom leta efter möjligheter hela tiden, att vara, det beror på vilket typ av bolag du är ju också.
Det är olika bolag som har olika kärnbeteenden kanske, men många av dem måste bara öva på.
Vi tror väl att en del av det handlar om beteenden som du kan behöva träna på.
Det räcker med att träna på det en gång.
Nu ska du få träna på att förhandla, varsågod ut och förhandla.
Nu ska du tränna på att workshoppa kring en effektivisering av en verksamhet.
Varsågod ut och göra en presentation av det här.
Ni har en halvtimme på er.
Det är 8-20.
Det kommer inte att bli en snygg presentation.
Det förstår alla.
Men du kommer att få göra åtta olika mini-presentationer under den här kursen.
Vi märker bara det att första gången när man går in och ska jobba med främlingar en halvtimme så är alla lite yra i huvudet.
Det är det här med storming, performing, man ska hitta varandra och vem som ska leda i gruppen.
Och så märker man att det blir lite halvdans.
Då hjälps vi åt sen allihop så att alla grupper får redovisa lite tillsammans.
Ger man det några veckor, shit vad folk bara på den tiden utvecklas i att de blir något slags, du är ett kirurgteam med någon som bara okej jag tar anteckningar, bra jag gör presentationen här, ge mig skallpellen, punktlistan, du går ut och tjatar till er och gör den här grejen, du tar fram en liten bild, bam bam bam bam.
Så de har gjort någonting som bara, okej.
När man släpper garden lite och har blivit lite bekväm med gruppen så blir man bara mycket bättre på att samarbeta och det märker vi bara under en kort tid.
Mycket är att man tränar praktiskt på små saker och det gör att man befäster den där turin.
Vi säger några saker under kursen.
På onsdag varje vecka så har vi att vi vänder och vrider lite på det ihop och vi ber alla att ge exempel på någonting från sin egen verksamhet som industrerar det här och sen så på fredag så lös man case ihop och då befästs det.
Så det är väl ungefär så vi försöker göra det.
Med det sagt så är det såklart att du blir ju inte finansierad analytiker på den här kursen.
Man kommer ju bara så djupt på det vill säga att vi är ju, du kommer vara ganska ytlig på ganska många områden, men du kanske vet också vad du inte vet.
Du vet att ska du köpa ett bolag så finns det några olika typer av dd du ska göra och du förstår nog ganska snabbt efter vår utbildning att man gör ofta en juridisk dd men du gör det nog inte själv.
Men det är ungefär de här sakerna du tittar efter.
Då vet du ungefär, då kan du ha en dialog med en jurist om du ska köpa ett bolag.
Det hände ju, vi har ju haft en deltagare som direkt efter kursen gick ut och köpte en fabrik.
Det var mycket att han visste vad han inte visste också.
Men det är svårt.
Det är det där som gör att vi itererar det ganska mycket också.
Hur får vi folk att göra de här små övningarna?
Hur kan vi strukturera de här workshopsen så att man hur kan vi knyta ihop saker mellan olika workshops och dra paralleller så att man vet att repeterar saker.
Känner ni igen det här från det där förra caset vi kollade på?
Om ni jämför de här tre affärsmöjligheterna som vi har kollat på nu, vilken hade du själv nappat bäst på varför och sådär?
Det är ett ständigt jobb.
Det är en helt annan grej än att försöka sätta ihop en en dagars kurs.
Definitivt.
Det är ganska mycket studierektorsarbete.
Vad är det som gör, och nu menar jag den här frågan med, jag försöker ställa den på ett kärleksfullt sätt men den kommer att låta jättedryg, men vad är det som gör er två lämpade för att hålla den här utbildningen?
Eller för ni kommer inte från utbildningsväsendet eller pedagogiken, alltså förstår du vad jag menar och jag fiskar efter, varför skulle det här vara en bättre utbildning än någon annan?
Vad är det ni gör duktigt liksom?
Nej men det är hybris, vi hör det.
Det är den här insecure over receiver Gregen.
Ja, nej men jag har bara tänkt på det här väldigt länge.
Det är många år sedan jag hade en tråd med en av killarna vi intervjuar i kursen, som är såhär, borde man inte bara kunna sammanfatta ner handels på tre månader.
Tanken har legat där och grott ganska länge.
Det är klart att lite måste man ha på CVT för att kunna göra det tror jag.
Tanken slog mig att göra något liknande för tio år sedan, men då hade jag inte kunnat göra det.
Jag hade ingen bakgrund, jag hade ingen reach, jag hade inte kunnat få tag i några deltagare.
Så det är klart att vissa saker låg rätt i tiden för att kunna göra det.
Men sen, vi är ju väldigt öppna med att säga att vi inte är redovisningskonsulter.
Men vi kan ju definitivt prata runt en årsredovisning.
Det kan vi göra, vi har sett ganska mycket årsredovisningar.
Men börjar det gå in i detalj så kommer vi att hänvisa vidare.
Vi har ju dessutom parat ihop en del av våra kunder med några av våra föreläsare.
Eller de vi intervjuar för att säga, okej men nu ska du göra en ganska stor säljstrategiförändring.
Men det är inte vi som gör det, utan ta någon av de här tre som vi har jobbat med.
Men vi hinner inte gå så pass djupt på de områdena under programmet så att vi inte bottnar.
Vi bottnar ganska bra ändå.
Och vill du bli expert på något av områdena så kan du definitivt peka på experter som kommer att göra det bättre inom respektive områden.
Jag bara hoppar tillbaks lite.
Vad är det som gjorde att ni var bra på den här utbildningen?
Är det att ni vet vart er gräns slutar att börja?
Ja men delvis är det väl så.
Det är väl också en kombination.
Vi har ju både drivit bolag själva och jobbat med investeringar.
Då får man kanske en viss kombination i alla fall av vad innebär det där att inte veta vad du håller på med och du hittar på allting.
Så att säga jämfört med att få lite paraplyperspektiv och plötsligt ha en hel portfölj och börja se likheter som där alla gör saker för första gången men du gör inte saker för första gången för du har varit med och sett kapitalanskaffningar många gånger.
Så den kombinationen tror jag ändå är vettig.
När vi pratar marknadsföring så pratar vi kanske inte att du har fått en budget och nu ska du exekvera den, utan vad ska du ens ha för budget?
Ska du ens tänka i termer av budget?
Om du är ägare hur ser du på din go to market?
Vi tror ändå att entreprenörsperspektivet är ganska viktigt i många bolag för att du ser på hela bolagsbygget från ett annat paraplyperspektiv.
Så det tror jag är vettigt.
Jag köper det, bra tanke.
Jag gillar det budgetexemplet där.
Jag tror att det gör det lite tydligt.
Ni har väl haft tre omgångar, fyra omgångar?
Sju omgångar, vi är inne på sjunde nu.
Helvet vad snabbt ni kör.
Kan du se någon generell kunskapslucka som du tycker att folk saknar?
Det är som när folk slutar gymnasiet, vad är de dåliga på att betala räkningar?
De har inte fattat vad OCR i numret är.
Kan du se någonting bland dina kursdeltagare att aha, är det här en kunskapslucka som folk har?
Det kunde jag inte tänka mig, det här borde alla ha lärt sig.
Oj, det är en väldigt stor fråga.
Det är förhandla med leverantörer, det borde ju folk ha lärt sig.
Ja men precis, jag tror att det är delvis det faktiskt.
Det är inte så mycket kunskap som att de inte har vissa beteenden.
Jag har en gammal lumpakompis som, han är den mest notoriska förhandlare du kan tänka dig.
Och i alla situationer som man kan förhandlas så förhandlar han.
Det är liksom en instinkt som, jag vill inte tro att antingen har du den eller också har du den inte.
Jag vill tro att du kan vänja dig vid att göra det lite oftare.
Jag köper liksom inte att man har inbyggda, alltså det är klart man har lite anlag, men du kan lära dig ganska mycket också.
Du kan alltid tillta dig lite åt ett håll och bli lite mer generellt vass.
Så det tror jag är, jag tror att beteenden faktiskt är en väldigt viktig del.
Men sen, vi frågar alltid inför, vi pratar alltid med alla deltagare innan de ska hoppa på, och vi frågar alltid varför väntar du att lära dig och så där.
Det där är så intressant för att man vet ju inte vad man inte kan.
Så att oftast det svar man får då är, någonting väldigt spetsigt som är, för att du kan en domän och du vet att det är några saker inom den domänen du inte kan, så därför svarar du så här, jag skulle vilja dubbelklicka på det här med aktivering av arbete, och lära mig lite mer detalj i skillnaderna mellan K2 och K3-bolag.
Och jag vet så här, aaah okej, nej det kommer vi nog inte gå igenom ska du säga.
Vi kommer att prata om aktivering av arbete, men vi kommer inte detalj i studerar K2 och K3.
Och så börjar personen kursen, och sen så du vet, så får man ett sms vid sidan av så här, du jag har fobi för Excel, kan vi börja från allra första början med Excel snälla?
Och då har man börjat inse, alltså du vet jag hade en deltagare, och jag vill inte hänga ut deltagare så jag nämner ju förstås ingen, utan vi hade en deltagare som, det var helt revolutionerande att få höra att du ska kanske ibland sälja först och köpa sen.
Så att den här personen kom till mig och sa då kanske vi inte ska köpa in den här jättedyra utrustningen innan vi har fått en kund till den.
Det kanske kan vara en klok idé sa jag.
Men då har jag sparat en halv miljon på den här utbildningen.
Det måste jag säga till min chef.
Det förvånar mig att man ena sidan vill prata k2-k3-bolag och sen så kommer det sådana där grejer.
Så jag har väldigt ödmjukt själv fått inse att man kan ha ganska köttiga CV'n och komma till oss.
Det visar sig att man faktiskt lär sig jättemycket, fast jag kan inte förutse vad det är de kommer att lära sig.
Jag får bara på något sätt, det är ungefär som att slänga ut marknadsföringsbudget och jag kan inte förutse hur många som kommer köpa den här veckan.
Jag får bara lita på att över tid så kommer det till er det och ibland kommer det på stötvis, ibland så kommer det...
På samma sätt, jag har tagit fram ett program, jag är något sådant tröje i mixen av innehåll och det har visat sig att olika människor lär sig lite olika saker på det.
Ibland är det saker som jag tycker är mer uppenbara än andra, att det här borde du väl ändå ha fått innan.
Men jag har full respekt för att, vadå?
Ibland handlar det om en formulering.
Ibland handlar det om att någon bara säger det på ett lite annorlunda sätt i lite rätt tidpunkt så bara sätter det sig.
Då får det vara så liksom.
En annan grej som jag tänkte på var, den har lite mer med hur ni driver bolaget, men det finns ju rätt mycket kurser eller vd-utbildningar, eller styrelseutbildningar, eller alla möjliga dagar och sånt där.
Jag tror att jag skulle nog underdriva om jag säger att en gång i veckan får jag ett sånt meldande på Lindgren, hej vill du gå den här kursen eller sånt?
Hur, och detta är bara i Sverige, hur sticker man ut i det bruset?
Det måste vara rätt svårt att marknadsföra sin egen kurs.
Hur gör ni för att framställa som enika, och speciellt när det är lite generellt, vi pratade ju där i början om att det inte är helt lätt att pinpointa en kundgrupp.
Hur har ni gjort för att få in kunder?
Det är en mix av...
Jag tror i grund och botten handlar det om bra produkt.
Vi måste bara ha en bra produkt.
Om vi får en stor andel 10 av 10 på den, så är det nog så vi växer.
Det är nog vår bästa...
Om det inte var så, då kommer jag inte hålla.
Vi måste bara satsa på produkten.
Vi fick lova att höja priset för att vi fick raka 10 i någon omgång.
Då kände vi att nu är vi nog för billiga, så nu måste vi höja lite.
Nu är det lite mer rymligt.
Peppar och peppar-deltagarna har varit väldigt nöjda.
Det tror jag är grund och botten, för då sprider det sig.
Då är Volkan ganska öppna med att lägga upp sitt diplom på LinkedIn.
Man får väldigt mycket likes på det och det sprids genom det.
Det är nog kärnan i någon slags tillväxtstrategi.
Sen blir det ju att försöka skapa någon form av...
Vi får försöka haka på olika typer av forum, tror jag alla olika typer av frågor, så att vi inte till exempel blir blöd som ledarskapsutbildning.
För vi är ju inte ledarskapsutbildning.
Det finns hundra ledarskapsutbildningar.
Och vi pratar ledarskap en vecka av åtta, det gör vi definitivt.
Den är ganska introspektiv, vi pratar kultur och återigen beteenden, om man får hålla tal inför andra deltagare och så där.
Men mycket handlar om att visa delar av innehållet, att det faktiskt handlar om affärer mer än ledarskap tror jag.
Sen den stora skillnaden, vi försöker poängtera vad det är vi gör annorlunda, det är ju att vi sprider ut över tid, det är den stora skillnaden mot en kort kurs.
Vi tror ju att det helt enkelt sätter sig bättre om det får gå lite tid.
Sen är det rent, om jag ska vara lite självkritisk, eller vad ska man säga, jag tror att ett bra vd-nätverk till exempel, är ett absolut fullgott substitut till oss.
Men sen finns det ganska många vd-nätverk och jag tror inte alla är så bra.
Ja, jag har lurats in i x antal vd-nätverk och jag har alltid slutat de vd-nätverken för att i slutändan blir det att folk sitter och dricker kaffe och frågar hur livet är och det är kanske inte det man ska utnyttja varandra till under den en och en halv timme som har lyckats få undan.
Man behöver nog göra det lite branschrelevant, man behöver göra det i rätt fas, det behöver vara bra guidning, bra guidade diskussioner.
Men jag tycker att poängen är väl att det behöver ske över tid.
Du behöver kunna vara i din normala verklighet och sen blir det intelektuella gymmet.
Det är väl så vi möjligen försöker pitcha det.
Det tar inte så mycket arbetstid och det är någonting som...
Jag hoppas att det lyser igenom att vi tycker att vi brinner för det vi gör och tycker att det är kul, egentligen är det inte roligt att sprida kunskap.
Det är ju någonting som är lite skillnad.
Det är vi som är bolaget mer än...
Och vi får ganska mycket cred för att vi kompletterar varandra rätt bra.
Jag är lite historielös och liksom lite sådär...
Jag gillar det nya, coola och vill hitta nya tekniker och nya arbetssätt och sådär.
Mattias är mycket mer sådär...
Nej men det här har vi sett hundra gånger förut.
Tittar vi historiskt så händer det här och här och här och du kan dra paralleller med de här bolagen som var verksamma 40 år sedan.
Det här är liksom inget nytt.
Han sätter saker i en makrokontext på ett sätt som jag inte gör ibland.
Han är otroligt duktig på att fånga upp deltagare och bara förtydliga saker extra mycket.
Ta ner bullshit-faktorn och räta ut frågetecken.
Så jag tror inte mycket i det också.
Vi kompletterar varmt bra.
Det är ju extremt tydligt att du brinner för detta.
Det är ganska roligt.
Vi hade i princip bara kunnat säga kan du inte bara prata om lärande här i 45 minuter?
Det känns som att du hade matat på här.
Eller i kursens aspekt liksom.
Men du sa att ni har kört sju omgångar här nu.
Är det så här kursen kommer vara framöver?
Eller har ni någon sorts grandiose plan kring detta?
Eller är det bara att det är jävligt kul som det är?
Alltså man säger alltid så här vad ser ni om fem år?
Men det verkar alltid finnas en förväntan på att man ska växa 8000 gånger.
Men en kunskapsöverföring eller en sån här kurs blir ju till sin natur ibland lite charmerande av att inte bli för stor för då känner du alla kursdeltagare, du får vara med i alla kursdeltagare och det kanske kan vara det mest givande i den.
Så därför tycker jag det är lite intressant att se hur du ser på, om du fick drömma liksom, hur ska det här utvecklas sig?
Alltså vi har ju inte valt att aktivt att inte göra det här som en e-learning-produkt till exempel, där du inte träffar människor utan gör det själv.
Vi har ju respekt för att det passar inte alla det sättet vi gör det nu, så vi kommer förmodligen att erbjuda någon slags mindre version av det för dem som verkligen är uppdagna och verkligen inte vill träffa andra människor.
Det kommer vi förmodligen behöva göra så att säga.
Jag är precis som du säger, kan vi ha ett par hundra deltagare om året som går den här utbildningen?
Vi har fyra startar om året och vi vill känna alla deltagare och vi bygger över tid ett väldigt kul alumnienätverk av människor som kan börja hjälpa varandra.
Nu har vi redan börjat se att det är knutskontakter och det börjar man hjälpa varandra med affärer.
Vi har börjat uppstå ett litet sådant här mjukvarunätverk som en del av alumnienätverk i gruppen.
Vi har börjat uppstå ett litet sådant här frilansernätverk.
Vi kommer att börja köra lite sådana här alumnidigitala träffar och sådär.
Nu senast på temat konkursbon.
Vi hade några alumner som vi var intresserade av att köpa konkursbon eller förmedla konkursbon och så där.
Och vi kunde facilitera med en kille som var proffspårare.
Så vill jag nog ha det.
Vi ser nog det här som att kan vi göra det här över en längre tid.
Vi måste ju hålla innehållet fräscht, men kan vi göra det över en längre tid och få engagerade personer som vi kan ju facilitera att de håller kontakt efteråt.
Men det är väl jättekul.
Jag blev ju så genuint stolt när min deltagare från första gruppen gick och köpte den där fabriken.
Det är klart att jag inte kan ta credd för det, men jag var en liten del av den resan och jag tycker att det är så förbannat coolt.
Är det någon som vågat ha klivit efter vår utbildning, starta egen?
Är du den som, när han lägger upp dig på, du vet han har sin tioårsdag på LinkedIn, då lägger han upp att det var tio år sen jag köpte fabriken.
Är du den där som går och kommenterar då?
Det var ju en vecka efter du hade gått vår kurs.
Jag kan inte lova något.
Jag kan inte lova att jag inte kommer göra det.
Jens, jag är jättetacksam för att du har med mig avsnittet.
Det har varit väldigt kul att höra hur en sån här utbildar.
Det är själv ett sånt där passionsprojekt som jag hade kunnat tänka mig göra om 20 år.
Jag tycker också att det låter väldigt spännande att få utbilda folk och prata med folk och prata med duktiga, drivna människor som faktiskt vill göra det.
Det är det som är problemet med skolan, att alla vill inte vara där.
Det måste vara en fantastisk miljö att vara i någonting där folk faktiskt vill vara där.
Så tack för att vi fick följa med och lyssna på storyn lite grann.
Stort tack för att ni kom med.
Jag har fobi för Excel.